just a few steps and we travel back in
time a thousand years
sofia church is the oldest most
important religious site in eastern
europe
it's a unesco heritage site
and it's easy to see why
we are located now in the central part
of saint sophia cathedral
a 1 000 year old monument which was
built in 1011.
it is a symbol of our state
it is both ukraines and the world's
heritage
there are many authentic 11th century
frescos and mosaics preserved here
there is not such a large number of
preserved mosaics anywhere else in
eastern europe
here in front is a six meter mosaic
image of mother oranta
made out of millions of small pieces of
smolt
of 150 shades of different colors
above me is an image of christ
pantocrator surrounded by angels the
main treasure of sofia are the authentic
1 000 year old frescos and mosaics
it's impossible to take them down from
the wall to put them in boxes and place
in some bomb shelters
today same as 1 000 years ago
these mosaics are on the walls and they
are priceless
maintaining these valuable frescoes and
mosaics is a year-round task but since
the war began work has stopped
but one thing also stands out unlike
other important buildings there's no
defensive measures here to protect the
compound no sandbags or blast walls the
management of the church compound has
declared it a demilitarized zone
especially
on the first day of the war we had to
close the museum
at the moment all our museums are closed
for visitors and our monuments are
conserved
on the territory of the cathedral there
is no single military nor any weapons
there is only a small number of workers
who maintain the facilities
there's a saying in arabic trust in god
but tether your camel saint severe is
hoping that its status as one of the
oldest most important historical sites
in eastern europe will give it some
protection however the church compound
is surrounded by strategic sites
including key ministries
during the second world war it is said
that german bombers avoided targeting
the church but today not everyone shares
the belief that if the capital is
attacked again its cultural heritage
will be spared
so much so that this is now a common
sight statues boarded up and hidden away
imran khan al jazeera keeve